thank you I've been listening you guys
back there you sound like you're in a
pretty good mood and that's what sets us
apart yeah saw my mom today it was
alright I mean she didn't see me or
anything but pretty close
my friends are trying to talk me into
the prozac you know Oh Margaret you're
down take the Prozac Oh take the zola
take the paxil finally they all went on
it no I feel great terms I was them well
you know misery loves company you don't
believe me just look at a fly strip
[Music]
you'll never see a fly stuck there
saying go around
they're all getting tattoos you know got
one friend got a tattoo of a W on each
cheek when he bends over it says Wow
first Mother's Day must be real special
and they're getting piercings you know
and they're not just piercing the ears
and the nose is anymore they're you know
lips nipples navels piercing their labia
no yeah piercing their little giorgio
capes
what are you get up one day you go you
know the kids are in school
think I'll go get my left labia peers
thinking jeez how do they get through
the metal detectors at the air
irritating when I have to take my belt
off let alone my labia earring you know
that's why when I fly I wear the
clip-ons I'm in debt you ever get in
debt you know they call you yeah one guy
call me every day last week finally I
said look every month I put everyone I
owe into a hat pick three names I pay
those people have you called me one more
time I'm taking you out of the Hat
everyone's broke you know I saw a truck
right out here today on the side of the
door it said driver has no cash thought
I'm broke - I don't plaster it all over
the side of my car got a self-esteem
even if you're broke though you should
treat yourself to little things you know
I buy underwear put a new pair of
underwear on I feel like a million bucks
you know buy the jockey ones they're
100% cotton you can breathe and I'm
opening a pair the other day a little
piece of paper falls out onto the floor
pick it up
inspected by Mary Lou Wow thank God last
pair burst into flames
the Marylou's on the job I can walk her
on safe and my hunger except now every
time I wear him I think about her hey I
wonder what she's doing I wonder if
she's thinking about me already been in
my underwear she could at least call
I'm vacuuming my couch the other day
yeah I'm getting under the cushions real
good a little tag pokes out of there
inspected by I gotta flip it over I'm
like if it's Mary Lou I'm gettin out of
the house
dizzy Bonnie's been everywhere I know
what you inspect a pair of underwear for
anyway besides like a piece of glass I'd
be a bad day huh big old piece of coke
bottle in your underwear all day you'd
be like that I'll stand anyone here
inspect underwear I mean professionally
tell you whoever's inspecting our
underwear they're doing a good job you
never hear about a big underwear recall
see dan Rather on TV going we're calling
back the 92 what I happen to have on
right now wear my underwear way up here
the older you get the higher your
underwear get like rings on a tree
her 8090 years old your breasts are
inside them when you die they just pull
them up over your head
she's gone guiding her underwear tell
you it's got to be worse than death
staying past your welcome
especially professionally I never want
anyone to go she used to be good
athletes have it the worst you know
because you could see them failing like
George Foreman what's he doing fight
he's 48 years old you know when you sock
him and the Guddi pees a little
[Applause]
Oh spirited murderous sniff everybody
dies with me now and looking